Herr Kikmusin, sage ich Ihnen.
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Doktor.
Mein Name ist Schick, ich bin hier aus Den Satz. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich bin zu Ihnen gekommen, weil ich, ich bin Patient in der onkologischen Ambulanz.
Ich habe es bekommen dort regelmäßig alle zwei Wochen meine Therapie, eine Immuntherapie.
Dazu kann ich sagen, über mir ist letztes Jahr Lungenkrebs festgestellt worden, im April 2021.
Und dann habe ich nach der Diagnose, habe ich eine Radioschemotherapie bekommen bis Juli.
Weil es sehr gut angesprochen hat auf die Therapie, ist jetzt eine Erhaltungstherapie mit Immuntherapie begonnen worden, die ich alle zwei Wochen erhalte.
Und wenn ich schon bei meiner Krankengeschichte bin, kann ich sagen, dass ich auch vor ungefähr 10 Jahren, also 2012, hatte ich auch Brustkrebs gehabt auf der rechten Seite.
Und da bin ich damals operiert worden und dann nach bestrahlt worden und habe dann auch eine Immuntherapie bekommen für sieben Jahre.
Warum ich jetzt...
Das ist eine Appellation.
Da ist die Brust entfältmert.
Ja, das ist die Brust, oder?
Die ganze Brust, ja, eine Appellation.
Ja.
Und warum ich bei Ihnen bin, Herr Doktor?
Vielleicht hole ich da etwas mehr aus.
Ich bekomme ja seit letztes Jahr Juli meine Therapie in der Onkologie und ich hatte zwischendurch auch mal so eine Entlungenentzündung gehabt.
Der Doktor hat, der onkologische Doktor hat gesagt, es wäre eine Entzündung durch die Strahlentherapie bedingt, also eine Strahlentzündung.
Und da habe ich auch Kortison bekommen und dann war es auch ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich habe eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit mit der Luftprobleme.
Also vor allen Dingen, wenn ich mich jetzt belast oder treppensteige, dann oder wenn ich mich aufrege, ist meine Luft knapp.
Da habe ich Luftnot.
Okay, jetzt um die Aktuellen, die aktuelle Beschwerden sind Luftnot, wichtig?
Luftnot, ja.
Aber das andere sind die Schmerzen der Doktor.
Und zwar habe ich seit ungefähr drei Monaten habe ich Schmerzen hinten im Rücken zwischen den Schulterblättern.
Und die Schmerzen ziehen dann rechts über die Schulter und dann in beide Arme.
Und jetzt habe ich jetzt auch manchmal auch hier ein Druckgefühl hier auf der Brust.
Da, wo der Tumor auch sitzt, vermutlich, ich kann es nicht genau sagen, das ist mein Problem.
Weswegen ich jetzt auch Schmerzmedikamente einnehme und die reichen aber nicht ganz aus, die Schmerzmedikamente.
Aber diese Probleme kommen und gehen.
Also seit drei Monaten habe ich die ungefähr.
Aber jetzt ist ein bisschen mehr, finde ich.
Okay, verstehe. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht ganz gehört.
Seit ungefähr drei Monaten ist es jetzt permanent da.
Ich verstehe. Jetzt brauche ich ein paar Persönlich-Data und dann spreche ich.
Ja, naja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sabine Braun.
Sabine Braun.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Braun?
Ich bin jetzt 62 Jahre alt.
62 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie genau geboren?
Dritter März 1960.
1960.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
68 kg.
Okay, Frau Braun.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ungefähr seit drei Monaten Luft, Luft, Not und Schmerz im zivilischen Schulter im Beletter und in beiden Armen.
Richtig.
Richtig, ja.
Und jetzt ist neu, allerdings auch hier vorne ein bisschen beschwert.
Ein bisschen vor.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie lungen Krebs hatten.
Ja, deswegen habe ich auch eine Bestrahlung und Chemotherapie bekommen.
Bis letztes Jahr, Juli.
Können Sie mir bitte die Beschwerden beschreiben?
Drückend oder ziehend, stehend?
Wie sind Erziehend, würde ich sagen.
Ist diese Schmerzen sehr stark?
Unterschiedlich, mal mehr, mal weniger.
Okay, aber gibt es immer Schmerzen?
Ja, fast immer, kann man sagen.
Also wenn die Schmerzen mit den Klammenten einnehmen, wird es ein bisschen besser.
Besser, aber immer da.
Eigentlich ja.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich möchte über Luftnoten sprechen.
Die Luftnot trifft immer bei Belastung oder in den Luftraum auch?
Also manchmal, wenn ich mich aufrege, dann habe ich auch Luftnot.
Aber ansonsten hauptsächlich, wenn ich mich belaste, mit Treppenstreiken zum Beispiel.
Also Frau Braun, haben Sie höchstens?
Momentan nicht so viel, bisschen, ja, aber nicht, das war früher mal stärker, als ich die Bestrahlung bekommen hatte.
Jetzt ist nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt gibt es aber, das ist nicht sehr stark.
Richtig, also eher weniger.
Haben Sie Ausruf?
Nein.
Also Frau Braun, ich habe jetzt ein paar allgemeine Fragen und dann spielen wir noch einmal über Ihre allgemeine aktuelle Beschwerden.
Haben Sie noch andere Krankungen außer Lungenkrebs und ja?
Brustkrebs, ja.
Also eigentlich nur, ich habe Eierstockzüsten, aber die sind nie operiert worden, die sind nur beobachtet worden, sonst keine Krankheiten.
Noch an der Erkrankung und die Operationen.
Haben Sie, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, also bis auf die Brustkrebs, sonst nicht.
Okay, okay.
Hatten Sie in Vergangeneitung Fälle?
Keine Unfälle, nein.
Nein, nein.
Entschuldigen Sie mich Frau Braun, ich konnte nicht gut verstehen.
Was haben Sie mit Eierstockzüsten?
Ah, okay, okay.
Eierstockzüsten, ja.
Ich weiß nicht ob das wichtig ist, aber das ist mal festgestellt worden, dann waren die wieder weg.
Aber Sie haben jetzt kein Problem?
Nein, das war früher.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Schmerzmedikamente, ja.
Schmerzmedikamente, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Also, unterschiedlich, manchmal Ibuprofen, dann auch manchmal Novalgin und dann auch noch Tramadolol.
Tramadol, okay.
War er wieder richtig?
Ja, er war bei Bedarf nicht regelmäßig, leider ja.
Mein Arzt hat gesagt, es soll regelmäßig machen, aber das habe ich nicht gemacht, bis er.
Blaufen Sie?
Nicht mehr, ich habe aufgerührt.
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren mit dem Hafen aufgehört.
Wie lange hatten Sie gerauft?
Also, damit so 17, 18 angefangen, kann man ausrechnen, bis 60, über 40 Jahre bestimmt.
Wie viel haben Sie gerauft?
Ja, so ein paarzehn 20 Sekretten am Tag ungefähr.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Okay, ungefähr einschachten pro Tag?
Ja, ja.
Zünden Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Lieben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, mein Vater ist verstorben.
Ihre Eltern haben eine kransche Erkrankung?
Mein Vater ist am Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist jetzt auch schon älter, die hat auch so Krankheiten wie Zucker, Bluthochdruck.
Hat auch mal einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Also, ich habe früher als Einzelhandelskauf vorgearbeitet, also war Verkäuferin bei REWE.
Aber ich arbeite seit ungefähr zehn Jahren nicht mehr, nach der Brustkrebsoperation habe ich dann aufgehört mit dem Arbeiten.
Als Hausvorstandshause.
Prügerät nach Rente, dann sind Sie oder?
Also, ich habe noch keine Rente eingereicht, nein.
Okay, das stimmt.
Als Hausvorstand.
Ja, das stimmt.
Sind Sie verarbeitet?
Ja, ich bin verarbeitet.
Aber Sie sind Kinder?
Nein, wir haben keine Kinder.
Sind Sie allein?
Nein, ich lebe mit meiner Mutter zusammen. Wir sind verarbeitet.
Okay.
Auch wenn ich weiter Informationen brauche, können Sie, wie lange können Sie beschwerter voran laufen?
Oder wie viele Treppe können Sie laufen?
In der nächsten Zeit, sich das verändern, sich verändert sich.
Also, wenn ich ein Stockwerk laufe, habe ich schon Beschwerden.
Mehr schaffe ich auf dem Moment gar nicht.
Aber für die Veränderung ist das anders, oder?
Also, vor der Brustkrebs, vor der Lungenkrebs war es besser, war nicht so, seit Lungenkrebs habe ich zunehmend diese Probleme.
Und in den letzten Monaten ist es zunehmend.
Okay.
Brau, braun.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie Sie das sind.
Ich denke, dass es kommt von diesem Lungenkrebs immer, die ganze Zeit.
Also, die letzte CT-Untersuchung, die gemacht wurde, das zeigt, dass das sich zurückgebildet hat, aber immer noch da ist.
Also, nicht ganz weg, das ist der Lungenkrebs.
Mein Onkolo gesagt, dass es jetzt so nahe, dick verändert, aber man muss halt weiter kontrollieren.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob Sie mir ein anderes Schmerzmedikamente mitgeben können, wo ich dann einfach besser zurechtkommen kann mit dem Schmerzen.
Was meinen Sie? Können Sie mir etwas anderes verschreiben, ein Schmerzmedikament?
Frau Brau, wir können etwas machen, aber zuerst muss ich Sie für eine Lösung untersuchen.
Weil ich habe einen Verdacht auf, nicht Verdacht, aber Sie können eine Herzkrankheit haben.
Meinen Sie?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es um Herzen kommt, Herr Doktor. Ich habe noch nie etwas am Herzen gehabt, früher.
Ist das kommt vom Lungenkrebs bestimmt, oder?
Ja, Sie haben einen Lungenkrebs, aber ich möchte nur sicher gehen.
Sind Sie sicher, Herr Doktor? Nicht, dass wir jetzt unnötig Untersuchungen machen.
Ich will eigentlich nach Hause gehen, wie der jetzt.
Geben Sie mir doch einfach eine Tablette, dann kann ich nach Hause gehen, eine andere Schmerz Tablette.
Nein, wir müssen sicher sein. Sie können auch, wenn Sie nichts haben, oder nur das normal Schmerzen, Sie können auch gegen.
Aber wir müssen ja Sie gucken, wir müssen sicher sein, weil das ist sehr wichtig.
Das kann eine Herzkrankheit sein, oder das ist auch eine Lungenentzündung.
Sie meinen, dass es unbedingt notwendig ist, dass ich jetzt erst mal die Untersuchung bekommen.
Ist das unbedingt notwendig?
Ja, natürlich. Das ist notwendig. Und wir müssen das sofort machen.
Jetzt werden wir sofort einen IKG untersuchen.
Okay, okay. Was wollen Sie noch machen aus IKG, Doktor?
Muss ich dann sagen, warten jetzt, oder?
Nein, nein, jetzt machen wir sofort. Die Schwester kommt gleich.
Und wir werden das jetzt sofort machen.
Okay. Und ein Röntgen veranlasst. Und wir werden sehen, ob Sie einen Herzkrankheit oder einen neuen Lungenentzündung haben.
Okay, gut. Und dann sprechen wir weiter.
Okay, gut. Aber nur in IKG, sonst nichts anderes, oder?
IKG und ein Röntgen. Und gegebenenfalls ein CT-Tour, das können wir machen.
Ich werde Ihnen einen Brut abnehmen und Ihre Effekte für Entzündungswerte konstruieren.
Ja, Sie haben eine werte Frankheit.
Okay, gut.
Gut, anverstanden, Doktor. Wenn Sie das für den Röntgen nicht erachten, dann mache ich das gerne.
Sehr gut. Frau Braun, bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Sie warten da und die Schwester kommt gleich.
Alles klar, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Gut.
So, gibt es Fragen aus dem Auditorium von den Zuhörern, die noch etwas gefragt hätten oder etwas wissen wollten zu der Patientin?
Gibt es Fragen, die nicht gestellt worden sind, die Sie gerne stellen würden, um die Krankheiten näher zu erfragen?
Okay, sehr gut.
Was ist denn das für die IKG?
IKG abtück, Sinusrythmus, ist Chemie, kann ich Chemie zeichnen.
Jetzt sind Vergleich zum Vor-KG keine wesentliche Änderungen. Also vielleicht ein kleines Q, vielleicht aber keine ST-Hebungen.
Was machen Sie weiter jetzt?
Kann ich ein Echo machen?
Ich habe es gemacht, bis die Rechtszeitbelastung, keine Wandbewegungsstörungen.
Ja, ich kann auch Herz-Enzyme bestimmen.
Troponin.
0,18 erhöht.
Ja, wir können sagen, jetzt die Patientin Herzgrenkeit hat.
Und ja, wir können sofort mit Heparin oder jetzt ich kenne die.
Ja, ich habe jetzt nur so vorab mal gesagt, das ist ein Fall aus meiner Vor-10-Tange, habe ich diese Patienten gesehen.
Und in der Tat war das so, dass das Erstdiagnose 3 Gefäß Corona Herzkrankheits, 3 Gefäß KHK sogar.
Mit kompletten Verschluss der RCA, rechte Granzaterie und die anderen hochgradig 90, 75% Stenose.
Vorher nie was gehabt am Herzen.
Okay, aber also die anonystischen Fragen waren sehr gut.
Was ich noch mal versucht hätte zu fragen, nochmal von der Patientin zu erfahren, ob diese Schmerzen auch belastungsabhängig sind.
Ob die Schmerzen bei Belastung zunehmen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das gefragt haben, Sie haben verschiedene Sachen gefragt, die Luftnoten.
Ich wollte das fragen, aber ich konnte nicht gut erklären.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, haben Sie diese Beschwerden nur bei Belastung oder in Ruhe, habe ich gesagt, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht ganz wichtig.
Sie hat es so verstanden, dass Sie nach Luftnot gefragt haben, ob Sie die Luftnot bei Belastung hat.
Das ist auch so, aber die Schmerzen sind bei Belastung nicht ganz klar.
Es war schwierig bei der Patientin, aber sie werden auch ein bisschen mehr, wenn sie sich belastet.
Aber es ist sehr, sag ich mal, untypische Beschwerdebild.
Also dass Sie jetzt auf die Herzproblematik gekommen sind, ist eigentlich ein sehr gutes Ergebnis.
Ansonsten hätte ich noch gefragt, ob es vielleicht Zeichen der Herzinsuffizienz gibt.
Was kann man da fragen?
Ja, vielleicht können wir bei Ihnen den Fragen.
Zum Beispiel, genau.
Autopne.
Autopne, ja.
Und wenn Sie liegen oder sitzen, dass Sie atmen, kann das auch eine gute Frage.
Ja, weitere Fragen.
Takikade, takikade, takukade.
Takikade, hypotonie.
Ich trage das nicht, aber ich trage es nicht.
Bitte?
Und hinten über die Schulter in beide Arme.
Hier unten ein bisschen vorne.
Und vorne ein bisschen erst letzter Zeit, ja.
Und seit drei Monaten übrigens, ja.
Also ich habe mich auch geärgert, weil ich die Patienten behandelt habe die ganze Zeit.
Und die hat immer wieder so Probleme gegeben.
Ich habe nie gedacht, dass sie ein Herzproblem hat, ja.
Ja, genau.
Also es ist bei ihr, die Diagnose war jetzt bei ihr NSDMI, also Nicht-Hebungs-Impakt,
bei einer Vorgeschichte an der Crescendo AP, Angina Pectores, ja.
Angina Pectores über drei Monate.
Ist wundtüblich, aber gibt es halt auch mal, muss man dran denken.
Gut, dann kommen wir zu Oberarztvorstellung, würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Okay, bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Ratz, ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie früher nicht kurz Zeit?
Bitte schön, ja.
Okay.
Schmerzen, Trätin auf Belastung.
Trätin bei Belastung auf.
Oder verstärken Sie sich bei Belastung?
Ja, verstärken Sie sich bei Belastung.
Die Schmerzen verschieben, wenn sich zu niemand, seit ungefähr drei Monaten.
Richtig.
Und ich habe auch einen anderen Charakter, die Patientin über leichte Hüsten.
Und nach, die Patient kann, ich werde vorhin nur ein Stock laufen,
Trätin ein Stock laufen.
Die bekannte Folgerungen, bekannte Folgerungen,
erstock, Züsten, ohne dass es gibt, das unauffällig.
Und sie nimmt gegen Schmerzen, Überprofen, Novalgien und Tegramal bei Bedarf.
Sie ist jetzt nicht rauchern, aber früher hat sie seit 40 Jahren ungefähr
einschachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Aber sie trinkt kein Alkohol.
in der Familie in Anamnöde zeigten sich mein Vater Herzinfarkt und bei der Mutter alterielle
Hypertonie, Diabetes mellitus und Schlaganfall. Sie war Anselkaufrau, aber seit ungefähr
zehn Jahren arbeitet nicht. Sie ist verheiratet und liebt mit ihrem Mann. Ich habe den Verdacht auf
eine Herzinfarkt. Pynomonie und Herzschwache kommen auch in Betra. Das werde ich die Patienten
körperlich untersuchen und mit Abnehmen gegebenenfalls werde ich einen Röntgen-Towax und Herz-Eco
durchführen. Warum wollen Sie einen Röntgen-Towax machen, wenn ich frage da? Weil die Patient hat
Lungenkrebs und Hystralentherapie. Vielleicht können wir eine Lungenentzündung und Pynomonie
bestimmen. Aber hat sie Zeichen der Pynomonie sonst? Also nicht in Klitsche. Sie hat Luftmord und in
Verrgangenheit hat sie Lungenentzündung. Aber was würden Sie bei Lungenentzündung erwarten?
Also ich will wissen, warum Sie einen Röntgen-Towax machen. Was für klinische Zeichen für Lungenentzündung
hat die Patienten? Bitte erzählen Sie das mir mal. Die Luftmord hat Lungenkrebs und Lungenotzer
drei Monaten. Es gibt keine Pynomonie, die hat drei Monaten. Ja, ich glaube, sie haben das nicht.
Aber ich möchte das auslisten und vielleicht kann ich in der Lunge Pynomone oder eine Belastung
wenn die Patienten einen Herbstinfarkt hat, vielleicht seit drei Monaten, kann sie eine Lungenpläurelefusion haben.
Das können Sie klinisch und mit Ultraschall feststellen. Da brauchen Sie keine Röntgen, oder?
Ja, Sie haben das nicht. Aber ich verstehe schon, ihr bedürft,
dass die Lunge abzuklären. Was ist denn noch differentialdiagnostisch möglich?
Aus einer Lungenentzündung ist unwahrscheinlich, ich habe mal gesagt, kein Fieber, keine Auswurf,
keine Verstätte in dem Sinne, das kann trotzdem sein.
Ich habe Fieber nicht gefilmt. Aber eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose,
dafür ist vielleicht eine Bildgebung ganz gut. Was ist deine Differenzialdiagnose?
Herzschmerz, Herzinsuffizie ist möglich.
Das kann sein, das würden Sie mit dem Ultraschall vom Herzen, also Echokardikapri feststellen oder erkennen.
Aber jetzt mal auf die Lunge bezogen, was für eine Differenzialdiagnose ist denn noch wichtig?
Amboli. Ja, vielleicht ja.
Ja, der Amboli kommt auch im Betrag.
Dann würden Sie was machen?
Ja, ich kann im Labor die Demo...
Die sind bei der Patientin erhöht. Was machen Sie jetzt?
Was mache ich jetzt?
Ist die Demioklärm, wie viel kann ich machen?
Ja, aber das können Sie auch bei Chris-Patientin ohne die Demioklärm machen,
weil bei Chris-Patientin es zu 99,9% und die Demiore sind erhöht.
Ah, okay. Ich wusste es nicht.
Deswegen ist es bei Chris-Patientin keine gute Idee.
Aber wenn Sie ihn verlachten haben, haben Sie jetzt angiocte.
Ja, genau.
Statt Röntgen-Torax wird man dann gleich einen angiocte machen,
wenn Sie ihn verlachten hätten auf Lunge-Emboli.
Gut, aber jetzt habe ich ihn ja gesagt, die Patientin hat IKG mit keine ST-Hebung.
Also keine eindutigen Ischemic-Zeichen im IKG, aber hat erhöhtes Troponin.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Erhöhte Protein.
Troponin, nicht Protein, Troponin.
Mit der erhöhten Troponin haben wir, ich glaube, die Herzinfarkt festgestellt.
Jetzt müssen wir behandeln mit Anticoagulat.
Ja, aber Troponin kann ja auch mal erhöht sein bei einer Lunge-Emboli.
Gibt es ja auch manchmal.
Ich wusste es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Kann auch mal sein, aber so hoch vielleicht nicht, aber kann sein.
Aber was machen Sie denn jetzt, wenn Sie Troponin haben,
machen Sie gleich eine Behandlung oder was machen Sie da?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, Troponin ist ein früherer Zeichen für Herzinfarkt.
Und wir können nicht, glaube ich, für bürennoli-fische Therapie so führen.
Aber was muss man dann erst mal machen, um das festzustellen,
ob es wirklich ein Herzinfarkt ist?
Koronan-Geografie.
Ja, also Notfallkoronan-Geografie, das machen Sie als nächstes.
Und dann ist, weil der Patient dann die erstmal durchgeführte Koronan-Geografie zeigt,
eine Dreigefäßerkrankung mit Druckerlöschdenose.
Genau das ist so das, was man machen würde bei der Patient.
Ja, ja, ja, man kann nicht, kann es nicht.
Kein Problem.
Aber Herzinfarkt ist immer so eine Frage, die vorkommen kann bei so
FSB oder Fachsprachprüfung, an anderer Prüfung.
Das sollten Sie mir angucken, auch wissen.
Aber das war ja auch die Antworten, die waren ja alle okay.
Ja, manche haben noch drei Wochen, ich glaube, ich kann das machen.
Ja, klar.
Gut, jetzt sind wir bei den Medikamenten, die Sie gemacht haben.
Wir haben jetzt eine Angeografie gemacht.
Bei der Patientin war es ein bisschen kompliziert, weil sie Dreigefäßerkrankungen hatten.
Normalerweise bei der Konstellation hätte man eigentlich eine operative Therapie durchgeführt.
Das ging da ein bisschen hin und her mit Kardioshirurgen und Internisten.
Letztendlich haben wir wegen der Jungentkriegsprognose dann doch entschieden,
eine interventionelle Behandlung vorzunehmen mit PTA,
also Armeoplastie und Stentanlage.
Sie hatte zwei Stents drin.
Und jetzt wollten Sie noch etwas über die Medikamentenbehandlung sagen.
Vielleicht habe ich, ich habe es hier unter Wochen,
was für Medikamente Sie jetzt geben, weil Diagnose herztenfacht.
Ja, ich glaube, im Notaufnahme, in der Notaufnahme können wir sofort
ASS, Parin geben,
Parin bereichern und dann für Ambulanz oder für Haus, Zuhause.
Kann die Patientin
eine Kommadine nehmen,
also die Korbidogrel und ASS nehmen.
Und vielleicht können wir begleitet haben, zum Beispiel BetaBlocka oder AC Hammer zu füllen.
Genau, also in Deutschland gibt man keinen Komadinen mehr,
sondern man gibt dann direkt diese Pletschenaggregation, Doppelpletschenaggregationshammer.
Also ASS plus zum Beispiel Corbidogrel oder in dem Fall Trica-Cellua.
Also Brillik, also Pletschenaggregationshammer, kein Komadinen.
Gut. Jetzt eine Frage an Sie.
Also das war alles sehr gut bisher.
Haben Sie aus der Analyse der Patientin
irgendwelche Hinweise gefunden, die Sie in die Richtung
Herzenfachtdiagnose bewogen haben?
Also irgendwelche Risikofaktoren, die gesagt haben,
es könnte Herzenfacht sein, weil ich habe die Patienten
über drei Monate auch mitbehandelt und habe das nicht gemacht bis zuletzt,
wo ich dann dachte, jetzt muss man weiter gucken.
Ja, welche Angaben aus der Analyse sind
den Risikofaktoren, dass die Patienten eine Herzerkrankung haben könnte?
Ja, ich würde sagen, sie ist ja als ein
Pomangenetiker, die familiären Belastung.
Ihr war ein Vater Herzenfachter und Mutter hat arterialen Hepatonin.
Ja, okay.
Auch vielleicht, ja, Patientin ist ein unkologischer Patient.
Und Patientin ist das Risikofaktor?
Die Krankheit oder überlegen Sie mal, die Krankheit selbst ist
jetzt nicht das Risikofaktor.
Nein, nein, ich würde das nicht sagen.
Ich würde sagen, ja, aus diesem Mund, vielleicht kann die
Patienten sich nicht so viel beregen.
Okay.
Und vielleicht auch ein Risikofaktor.
Was noch?
Ja, Alter.
Alter, die ist noch nicht so alt,
zwanzig Jahre alt ist noch nicht so alt, oder?
Herzinfacht ist eher jung, würde ich sagen.
Das ist kein Risikofaktor.
Rauchen. Rauchen, okay.
Genau, Rauchen.
Vielleicht die Adipose.
Die ist nicht adipose, die war normalgewichtig.
88 kg.
Ja, 68 kg hat sie gesagt.
68 kg.
Aber da hat jemand im Chat was Gutes geschrieben.
Strahlung, absolut richtig, sehr gut.
Die ist bestrahlt worden, sowohl Brust als auch Lunge.
Da ist das Mediasinum bestrahlt worden.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor für Coronareherserkrankungen.
Also Bestechterung der Coronarenherserkrankungen.
Sehr gut.
Was noch für Risikofaktoren?
Mir fällt noch einer ein.
Wobei das jetzt nicht unbedingt Risikofaktor ist, aber
wird immer wieder diskutiert.
Stress.
Stress, ja.
Die hat Handkrebs, hat
die Stress im Kopf und weiß nicht, wie Prognose ist und so weiter.
Ja.
Was längst du mal an die Medikamente, die sie einen nimmt?
Gibt es noch eins, was sie?
Im Ordnement.
Bitte.
Kann man Parasiten auch so etwas
ursachen?
Ja, aber es ist nicht so.
Das ist nicht so klasse.
Das geht nicht so klasse.
Ich gebe andere Medikamente, die zum Beispiel
Coronaspassmann auslösen können, hat sie aber jetzt nicht bekommen.
Ja, aber
kann man jetzt nicht ganz ausstehen, haben sie recht.
Aber einen Medikament, was sie einnimmt jeden Tag.
Die U-Profen.
Ja.
Was mit dem Profen gehen?
Was mit dem Profen?
Ist die Profen gut für Herzpatienten?
Herzpunkte?
Ja, ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Wer weiß es?
Eine Risikofaktor.
Aber warum?
Non-Sterite-Antemplarmotor-Druck
ist eine Risikofaktor, neue.
Also, man muss sagen, die ganzen alten NSA,
Walter Reh, die Profen, die haben wir,
geben wir immer ganz gern, aber das gab wir dann auch neue,
zum Beispiel diese COX-2-Hemmer,
die sind dann, also wie zum Beispiel
Celecoxib oder
ich kenne es nicht alle im Prinzip,
die sind dann damals vom Markt genommen worden,
kurzfristig, weil in diesen Studien
das Herzinfarktrisiko erhöht war bei den Patienten.
Und dann hat man retrospectiv geschaut,
auch bei anderen nicht-sterite Ante-Romantik-Authentren
wie Profen oder Walter Reh,
in der Tat ist auch da das Risiko von Herzkomplikation,
Herzinfarkten erhöht.
Also, das scheint eine Substanzklasseneffekt zu sein.
Ja.
Also, natürlich nicht bei Gesundem.
Wenn jemand gesund ist, dann kann er aber
obwohl er das nicht mal bei Patienten, die schon eine KKK haben,
kann das vielleicht eine Verstechterung machen.
Ja.
Ja, danke für die Informations-
Ja, alles klar.
Und NSA-De-Köntorgschmerzen blockieren,
das kann dann verschleiern.
Dann drei Monate lang die Patienten mit
Crescendo angina pectoris ist es ja gewesen.
Also, früher gab es ja den Begriff
endstemin nichts.
Als ich studiert habe, gab es kein endstemin.
Da gab es angina pectoris,
stabil und instabil angina pectoris.
Dieses endstemis erst entstanden,
nachdem man diese ganzen Herzinzyme
in den diagnostischen Algorithmus eingebunden hat.
Früher hieß es alles Präherzenfakt oder angina pectoris.
Also, also dieser Fall kann unter dem Titel laufen,
Crescendo angina pectoris,
dann mal auf endstemi bei Lungrebs.
Gibt es dazu noch Fragen oder Kommentare?
Aber die Anamese war sehr gut
und auch der Schluss,
dass man die Patienten überredet hat,
nicht nach Hause zu gehen,
ist auch sehr, sehr gut gewesen.